[Musique]
on arrive dans quelques instants regardé
comme tout le monde s'affaire tout le
monde est beau tout le monde est prêt
caroline se recoiffe thibault sel sucre
tape sur les jours c'est pas trop pour
moi on me crottes
voilà ça porte bonheur petites tapes sur
le cul cul ça a bien voilà on chez nous
qu est ce que tu manges dos les
polémiques à malherbe
et toi de tout qu'est ce que tu manges
tu as tout à ça a l'air bon en tout cas
vous aimiez une star cas dans mon bureau
vide sous mac do oh la la
mike palocci tient bien et puis j'aime
bien tu te tiens bien lasser c'est une
star car un bureau tant qu'on aura
beaucoup soient pas vu de moi se
déclenche la réplique pour croiser aux
trois équipes à cela allez gillou porte
les affaires de fatou heures c'est ton
devoir de porter les affaires de fatma
[Rires]
et
ah ah
alalalala
kelly a décidé de prendre un nouveau
départ devenir rousse
pourquoi quelles idées changent de vie
quelles sont les raisons négoce vous
n'êtes pas allé sept chats mais j'adore
alors il fait comme dame qui fait des
synapses toute la journée
quand le roi je travaille me suis mal
coiffé avec mon ami ben ça va bien merci
pour le cadeau un très beau cadeau que
tu m'as fait d un gain
[Musique]
meriaux la sncf le nom à l'école de nuit
à bien de manger maxou voilà là je suis
revenu non mais vraiment est ce que ta
phin découvertes gustatives émotionnel
je vous conseille aux arrêts
[Musique]
merci à tous merci à toi merci les fon
ces faits là c'est pour qui ces poulets
et mathilde
attention daniel awa
[Musique]
un énorme kelly ce soir les b c'est ta
première c'est important c'est comme la
première fois quand on fait l'amour
c'est pas la plus agréable
l'on se souvient toute sa vie voilà
[Musique]
m
là
[Musique]